drei zu viel besser als luca und wir
spielen heute hätte soccer in minecraft
ich habe heute auch ein gast julius beck
in dem bild aldi hat den umzug auf jeden
fall auch gut überstanden wir jetzt
erstmal kommen möglichst einen eigenen
ihren platz cd bestehen so cool ist
dabei heute das ist eine map von msi
macchio follow me and you tube hey es
ist herzog an minecraft so wie ich das
am anfang schon gesagt habe und zwar
herzog ist dieses spiel auf dem handy wo
du so gegen ich zeig euch einfach mal so
sieht das ganze aus wie hier als man hat
so ein stadion muss halt so
gegeneinander zu kämpfen und hat
verschiedene power schüsse und steht
quasi arena und zockt anhalt seit wann
gibt es in dem spiel mädels es ist ein
2d spiel wo man ein spieler spielt man
muss den ball ins gegnerische torwart
luca einmal wie ein profi bitte das ist
die map von msi maki stein wir können
uns entweder aussuchen ob wir uns die
single bleiben beim runterladen oder die
multiplayer map ich habe mir die single
player herunter geladen weil ich habe
keine freunde
in dieser seite steht der mtv stein
gegen dem wir halt im singleplayer
antreten der kammel wieder sagen dass er
aus deutschland kommen soll oder aus
österreich oder kanada aus amerika oder
aus japan das sind die fünf
verschiedenen sachen dann sagen wir
einfach mal dass der aus amerika kommen
soll dann haben wir die quasi aus
amerika und ich laufe jetzt rüber zu
meiner seite und wer jetzt
beispielsweise einfach mal hier
deutschland aus kann hier hin laufen in
dem blauen fahrrad und jetzt kann ich
quasi steuern indem ich nach links mit
dem gehe ich nach rechts ich kam mit
space springen
der war drin da ist das tor das 1 0
des weiteren kann ich mit schiff zum
kleinen sondern pusch bekomme ich
dadurch nach vorne hier warte ich zeige
euch das mal oder nach hinten
dementsprechend schon jetzt meinen
porsche müssten sie die 1 funktion
aktivieren
mit der einlass funktion können sie die
umschalt steuerung alte darunter auch
hier mit shift zack da kriege ich einen
kleinen push und wenn mein balkon oben
voll ist kann ich verstehen eins zu eins
denn mein balken oben links volles genau
dann kann er macht jetzt gerade seinen
vorschuss jetzt habe ich allerdings auch
den ball
und jetzt mache ich meinen vorschuss und
bam 221 freunde wir haben glaubt es
steht 2 2
wir haben glaube ich keinen sound bei
dem spieler sich auf dem sound
eigentlich volle pulle an
aber dann macht ihr einfach die musik
mal ein bisschen lauter leute mit lauter
musik bleibt alles viel besser hier war
er hat das 3 2 geschossen cool geil
amerika super da hilft nur der patient
steht 4 2 für ihn darum drei zu vier ich
finde die fans auch rechtsstaat mein
gott ist das viel zu viel ist das jetzt
wieder als ob junge wie stark ist der
emittent
geil und politik das was du jetzt
geschafft hast war von einem 36 auf 1
428 zu kommen war stark es steht 4 zu 9
das ganze spiel geht bis 10 das heißt um
zu gewinnen haben wir doch eine recht
knappe chance aber wir haben es mit dem
vorstoß und 50 muss jetzt irgendwie
seinen power schuss abwehren weil den
hat er jetzt gerade oh mein gott ich bin
mir sehr sicher dass es an den ländern
liegt ich gebe ihm jetzt mal deutschland
soll dann hat er erst mal deutschland
und ich hole mir mal selbst irgendwie
wenn hole ich bekomme ich noch einmal
apa die ich kriegen dass er immer ganz
gut hin
und jetzt freunde es wird einen 10 zu 0
man kann man kann hier nicht sagen okay
spiel gut oder nicht es kam ein gott der
muss rein
der muss ein der muss da ist das 11
freunde jetzt richtig los dann wird halt
nur zehn zu eins anstatt medizin zu null
fest steht 2 1 für ihn
ich mag die spiele jetzt schon nicht
mein gott bauausschuss machen 1 lukas 1
genau vier zu eins hits hat nun zehn zu
viel
okay hier fünf zu eins in ordnung da
kann doch nur der powershot helfen der
muss sein alter es muss noch irgendeine
chance geben dass ich einfach mal so ein
spiel befindet diese leute sind einfach
viel zu stark für dieses mittel da der
muss rein der muss rein die springt der
denkmal dasteht krankhafter im publikum
es steht 2 zu sieben ich habe power
schuss am 13 7 13 zu 7 mein gott komme
jetzt die aufholjagd 2010 hatten power
schuss ich habe ihn abgeblockt 8 zu 3
für ihn das ist wieder ein tolles
ergebnis du da sage ich mir direkt da
steht ein typ mit noten blog auf den
kopf und ich kassiere gerade das nein
doch nicht hier zu null
jetzt auch eben den bauausschuss schnell
rein machen und stets 15 habe ich
zumindest einmal die hälfte erreicht
sagt schuss ab rein ins tor
bild zu machen ja freunde das war's mit
rocket liegt mit zockern minecraft es
das jetzt ich hoffe dass heute ich hoffe
ende noch nicht ende ich wollte mal ganz
kurz fragen was haltet ihr von
livestreams ich bin jetzt in der neuen
wohnung wenn internet läuft stabil ich
habe gut abgedichteten raum so dass man
keine nebengeräusche höher und ich bin
im youtube-stream beta programm mit
irgendwie nach an voll anderen youtube
oder sogar ich das ist nicht dieses
komische google+ hangout chip ding
sondern das ist so ein youtube gaming
livestream wo man einfach auf
youtube.com schrägstrich von crafter
schrägstrich leid das mein live stream
der wird wenn ihr darauf denkt
wahrscheinlich offline sein weil ich
gerade offline bin obwohl ich eigentlich
wenn ihr wollt dass sich da eventuell
malaga rio lässt die macher valerius
glaube ich so das perfekte spiel was man
nicht ausgelutscht ist neben macht
dieses spiel einfach unglaublich viel
spaß
ich weiß nicht ob man das in den videos
merkt habe ich spiele dieses spiel
tatsächlich immer auch wenn grad video
rändern oder so wollt ihr dass ich mal
live stream mache auf youtube.com
schließlich kontrakt erschreckt sich
live dann werde ich das demnächst mal
machen wenn ich zeit habe hey lassen wir
das